Hi, welcome back. In this session, we're
going to talk about valuation and
pricing. Now, you say, what's the
difference? Well, as we will see during
the session, the words might often be
used interchangeably, but they mean very
different things. Of course, we could do
a whole class on valuation and pricing,
and I do, but this is about giving just
enough information for you to be able to
use it in the context of investing. So,
let's set the stage.
If you have to look at an investment,
there are two ways you can put a number
on it. The first is you can value it
based on what the cash flows and the
growth and the risk as a business as an
investment. That's valuation. We call
that intrinsic value. You might use a
discounted cash flow model to get there.
But there are some people might use
accounting ways of getting there. But
that's intrinsic valuation. You value an
asset based on its cash flows. You say,
what else can you do? You can price it.
What's pricing? It's set on by demand
and supply, mood, and momentum. It's
based on what people are willing to pay
for that investment. How do you estimate
it? By looking at investments just like
these and looking at what other people
are paying for those investments. Sounds
mysterious, right? But have you ever
used a P ratio and comparable companies
to price a company? You price a company,
you haven't valued the company. So I
want to talk a little bit about both at
least lay the foundations for both
because they both come into play in
investment philosophies. Let's start
with intrinsic valuation. In intrinsic
valuation you value an asset based on
its fundamentals. Its intrinsic
characteristics.
Now that might sound mysterious but
those intrinsic characteristics can be
captured in three components. Expected
cash flows and the growth in those cash
flows and the uncertainty you feel about
receiving those cash flows. Now, of
course, the tool that people often use
in the context of intrinsic valuation is
discounted cash flow valuation.
Discounted cash flow valuation just a
way of assessing intrinsic value by
first estimating the expected cash
flows, then estimating a discount rate
that reflects a risk and taking a
present value of the cash flows. In
fact, before we look at those inputs,
let's look at the two phases
of discounted cash flow valuation. The
most common one is to take expected cash
flows in the numerator. Those expected
cash flows if you're a business will
come from revenue growth and margins and
expectations about how the business will
do and discount them back at a risk
adjusted discount rate. We talked about
some of those risk adjustments in the
last two sessions. The present value of
the expected cash flows is the value of
an asset. But in the last session on
equity risk, we talked about an
alternative way of adjusting for risk
where instead of using expected cash
flows, you came up with certain
equivalents. We admitted that's not easy
to do. But investors often make
conservative estimates of cash flows,
account only cash flows you can you you
feel are pretty close to guaranteed. And
if that's the case, you're looking at
certain equivalent cash flows, you've
already adjusted for risk, you can
discount them back at the risk-free
rate. I have never seen and I'll be
quite honest I've never seen a good
valuation using the second approach
because it requires a whole lot of
dancing around estimates that people are
unwilling to do. So the first approach
is the more common one. Now within the
context
of a business there are two ways you can
approach valuation. One is you can focus
on valuing just the equity in the
business. Remember there are two ways
you can fund a business. You can borrow
the money debt or use your own money
equity. The equity cash flows are the
cash flows left over after everybody
else has been paid including the
lenders. Those are called cash flows to
equity. You discount them back at the
rate of return you demand as equity
invested. The cost of equity. You come
up with the value of equity in a
business. The other is to value the
entire business and that entire business
gets its value both from investments
it's already made. We call that assets
in place and growth assets, things
they're expected to do in the future.
Get familiar with this structure because
we're going to bring it back over and
over again during the course of this
class to draw a contrast between value
investing and growth investing. You
value a business, you look at the cash
flows to all claim holders. Remember,
now lenders are also claim holders. A
collective cash flow, a pre-debt cash
flow, it's called cash flow to the firm.
You discount it back at a discount rate
that reflects not just what equity
investors want, cost of equity, but all
what lenders want, which is the cost of
debt. That composite cost is called the
cost of capital. The present value that
you get is the value of the entire
business. Of course, you might still be
interested in equity in which case you
net out the debt you owe, you got the
value of the equity in a business. Now,
rather than get focused in on estimation
questions, when I think about discounted
cash flow valuations or intrinsic
valuation, I think of four questions to
which I need answers to value business.
The first is to the extent that the
company already has investments it's
made. What are the cash flows from those
existing investments? Those cash flows
can either be before debt payments, firm
cash flows or after debt payments. The
second question and this is really where
you trip up and you get uncertain is
what's the value expect to get from
growth assets? The investments are
expected to make in the future. Now that
value added as we will see can be great
if you're a company in that takes
investments that generate value but it
can also be neutral. You can grow and
not add value and grow and even destroy
value. That might puzzle you but we'll
come back and examine why. And again
that growth can either be to equity
investors
looking at equity earnings and cash
flows or to the entire firm. How risky
are those cash flows? Now you can draw
on what we've talked about the equity
risk and debt risk but you can either
focus on just the risk in the equity
using the CAPM or the arbitrage pricing
model or proxy model or whatever model
you've decided to use or the risk in the
entire firm risk in operations. And
there's a final question this might
puzzle you as to why you need the answer
is when will your firm become a mature
firm? You say what's a mature firm? A
mature firm is a firm growing at a rate
less than or equal to growth rate of the
economy. You're saying, "Why do I need
to know?" Because your job is to assess
the value of an asset. The value of an
asset is the present value, the expected
cash flows on that asset over its
lifetime. You still don't get it, right?
If a publicly traded company, it can at
least in theory keep going and going
forever. Nobody can estimate cash flows
forever. We want closure. We want to
stop estimating cash flows, but we can't
just ignore what happens after that. But
if I tell you that your firm will grow
at a constant rate forever beyond that
point in time, mathematics helps you by
giving you the value of those cash
flows. It's called a terminal value. But
you can do that only if your growth rate
is constant forever. Now do you see why
a mature firm assumption comes in? You
cannot grow at a rate faster than the
economy forever. Why? Because then
you'll become the economy. By telling me
when your firm become a mature firm,
you're telling me when I can put
closure. Ultimately all of intrinsic
valuation is trying to answer those
questions. You can see it show up in the
equation. So let's say you're trying to
value a business. The cash flows from
existing assets get you started. Those
are the numbers that are your starting
your base year numbers. The value of
growth shows up in two places. One is as
a growth rate you use to increase your
cash flows over time and revenues over
time. But also in the reinvestment you
got to put in to get that growth rate.
The net effect is what's going to
determine whether growth is going to add
value, do nothing for value, or destroy
value. The risk in the cash flow shows
up through the discount rate. And
finally, when you tell me your company
is ready to settle in, I compute that
value in a terminal value, the value of
the company in perpetuity if need be
once you put closure in. That's
essentially how DCFS connect up to the
questions you're trying to answer. Very
quickly talking about those inputs that
go in there, you talk about cash flows,
especially looking at cash flows to the
FU, which are pre-debt cash flows. You
can't start with net income because net
income is after interest expenses. And
this is a pre-debt cash flow. You have
to start with operating income. I mean,
this might sound obvious, but operating
income can actually be written as
revenues and operating margins. And the
reason I break it out is you forecast
operating income. You might start with
revenues and especially if your margins
are changing, estimate what your margins
will be over time. You have to net out
taxes, but not the taxes you actually
paid, but the taxes you would have paid
if that operating income are taxable.
You might say, why I don't pay taxes on
that? Because you don't want to double
count the tax benefits. You're saying,
what double count the tax benefits? The
next slide you're going to see discount
rates and dis the cost of debt is an
after tax cost of debt. It allows for
the tax benefits from debt and you don't
want to count those tax benefits again
in your cash flows. That's why we look
at the taxes you would have paid in your
operating income. You net out the
reinvestment and that reinvestment can
be in factories if you're a
manufacturing company, but it can also
be in things we call intangibles if
you're a non-manufacturing company. And
what you're left with is the free cash
flow to the firm. If you have to compute
free cash flow equity or one step away,
you bring in your debt payments,
interest payments, principal repayments,
and if you're borrowing money, that cash
flow as well, your free cash flow
equity. Cash flows are after taxes and
after reinvestment. And if the cash flow
is equity, they're after debt payments.
On discount rates, we've talked enough,
right? Previous session was all about
how to come up with that discount rate.
The CAPM it's captured with the beta end
as your measure of risk and equity risk
risk-f free rate but the I gave you
alternatives the arbitrage pricing model
multifactor models even proxy models
ultimately you come up with an expected
return on risky equity investment that's
your cost of equity your cost of capital
is a weighted average of that cost of
equity and your after tax cost of
borrowing money what what is that after
tax cost of borrowing money it's the
rate at which you can borrow money net
of the tax benefit you get from
borrowing
on growth itself. I want to first draw
your attention to a linkage that I think
is worth remembering especially over the
long term to grow. You can't just
magically just put in a number. You got
to reinvest money back into the business
and reinvest it well. The way we measure
those two dimensions depends on whether
you're looking at equity the entire
firm. If you're looking at equity, what
you reinvest will be what you don't pay
out in dividends, retained earnings or a
retention ratio. And how well you
reinvest will be captured the return on
equity you make on your investments.
With operating income, what you reinvest
can be captured with the reinvestment
rate. What you put into man, you know,
net capex, which is what accountants
measure as, you know, what you put into
long-term assets, net of depreciation,
and change in working capital. That's
what you have to reinvest to grow as a
percentage of your after tax operating
and how well you reinvest is captured
with your return on capital. So the risk
of stating the obvious it's easy to grow
just reinvest lot you do a lot of
acquisitions
but if you grow by with terrible returns
in equity and returns in capital you can
destroy value quality growth requires
that rare company that's able to
reinvest a lot and reinvest well at the
same time. Second, and this is a truism
that tends to hold at all companies. The
larger you get, the more difficult it
becomes to maintain these numbers. Think
of what reinvesting 80% of your after
tax operating income and earning a 30%
return on capital might not be a big
deal when you're a billion dollar
company, but it becomes a much bigger
deal when you're a hundred billion
dollar company. You got to take a lot
more projects and be able to deliver
that same return. And finally,
the risk of repeating what I've said,
you can grow and destroy value. The
return on capital you earn is less than
your cost of capital. The return equity
earned is less than your cost of equity.
And finally, the closure here comes from
making that assumption that you can grow
at a constant rate forever. What does
that give you? It gives you an infinite
series in mathematics. And 200 years
ago, mathematicians solve for that
series. We stole it in finance. We act
like we invented it. But here's what
goes into terminal value. First, you
have the operating income, and this is
the value of the entire firm. And you
can have an analogous equation for
equity. You look at the after tax
operating income in the year after your
terminal year. So you want to get the
terminal value in year 10, you have to
get the earnings in year 11. Why?
Because all present value equations
require an earnings one year out or a
cash flow one year out. You put aside
money to reinvest. How much depends on
your growth rate in perpetually. If you
want a 3% growth rate, you got to
reinvest more than if you want a 2%
growth rate. How much will depend on
your return in capital. So you have a
20% return in capital and you want to
grow 3% a year. You got to reinvest 15%.
You net that out. That becomes your cash
flow. And in your denominator you have
your cost of capital minus your growth
rate in perpetuity. Now I know people
look at and say what if my growth rate
is equal to my cost of capital. Remember
you can do this you know use this
approach to get the terminal value only
if you're a mature firm. that growth
rate has to be less than or equal to the
growth rate of the economy which means
by definition it'll be less than your
cost of capital. Those are the inputs
that drive value and an estimation that
opens you up to challenges and I'll know
set this up because it's going to come
into play as we look at different
investment philosophies. Your cash flows
from existing assets you got to be
comfortable enough with accounting to be
able to gauge what the company made to
estimate the value of growth. You need
to know the company's history. You need
to know what the competition is doing,
market potential. All of that research
is directed to assessing how quickly can
I grow and how much value for the risk
and the cash flows. You can look at past
prices, past earnings, what the pure
group looks like. And for steady state
to get a sense of what your company
look, you can look at the largest and
most mature companies in the space.
There is no simple template that I can
offer you that will work for every
company. And that's good, right? Because
otherwise chat JPT could do this. Your
job in assessing value comes with
challenges.
And those challenges and how you deal
with them is what separates great
investments from good investors to
average investors to bad investors.
At the risk of taking a valuation that's
very old. This was my Twitter preIPO
valuation October 27th of 2013. To get
their earnings, I had to start with
revenues. You're saying why did you just
take operating income? because they're a
money losing small company. But in my
valuation, I've taken those small
revenues and made them into big
revenues. Looking at the online
advertising market and telling a story
of Twitter being a successful online
advertising player, but a niche player,
not the main player. In my story, it
wasn't going to be a Facebook because,
you know, no company would just use
Twitter for all of its advertising. Over
time, I did assume the losses would not
just go away, but that the margins would
improve to 25% by looking at healthy
online advertising players. But I did
assume to grow, they would have to
reinvest a $150 of revenues for every
dollar of capital. The net effect is in
my valuation. If you look at my free
cash flows, they're big negative
numbers. But don't freak out. It's
exactly what you'd expect in a high
growth company with a lot of ambitions.
Eventually, the cash flows turn
positive. I assume the company becomes
mature after year 10 growing at a
constant rate forever. At least
initially I give them a really high cost
of capital. Why? They're a risky
company. They have a high beta.
They don't use much debt. That cost of
capital will decrease over time down
towards that of an average company, an
8% cost of capital. And in stable
growth, I do assume they can continue to
earn more than their cost of capital.
And while they're growing 2 and a half%,
they'll still have to reinvest to get
that growth.
All of those things I talked about in
the context of a generic valuation. You
see that play out in the cash flows. I
value Twitter at about $18 per share the
time of its IPO.
Mia Kalpa stock opened at $45 per share,
went up to 75. Eventually, it came back
down to 18. But I don't view that as
some kind of consolation price. But I
want to emphasize when you value a
company, don't expect the market to
agree with you. demand and supply mood
and momentum can yield a very different
answer.
So that's what drives value. You're
saying what can I do to change value?
This is something again we're going to
come back to in the context of looking
at activist investing as investment
philosophy. There you take an existing
company and you don't just take it as a
status quo. You try to change it. Change
it in what way? You try to get more cash
flows from existing assets.
cutting costs, being more efficient,
delivering more value from future
growth, either by earning a higher
return on capital on the projects you
take or reinvesting less in projects
that earn less than the cost of capital.
Lengthen out your growth bid by building
your barriers to entry or competitive
advantages. Lower your cost of capital,
changing the mix of debt and equity,
maybe using cheaper debt, lowering your
fixed cost, making your product less
discretionary.
All of those things can change the value
of a company and that effectively is
where the value increase from changing
management in a company comes from.
Now let's do it to price. What drives
price?
Well, could be fundamentals, but it
could also be mood and momentum, right?
Good moods drive up prices. Momentum is
in your favor. Prices go up, shifts,
prices go down. Liquidity clearly can
affect prices. the ease with which you
trade.
But with prices, with demand and supply,
you have this behavioral component of
group think. If everybody else is
buying, you feel the urge to buy. If
everybody else is panicking, you feel
the urge to panic. And finally, market
prices are determined not by by total
information, but by incremental
information. You say, "What does that
even mean?" Next time you see a high
growth company make an earnings report,
take a look at what happens. The
information in the report might be
minimal, but to the [clears throat]
extent that it beats expectations, the
price will react. The market price is
driven by forces that are very different
than the forces that drive value, which
means price can be different from value.
Stating the obvious, might as well. If
you're ever asked to price a company, if
that's what your investment philosophy
requires, here's how you go about
building to a pricing. First, you
standardize the price. What does that
mean? You can't compare price per share
across companies because it's in a sense
arbitrary. I do a two for one stock
split. My price halves doesn't make it
any cheaper. So you divide the price by
something by earnings by book value.
Price earnings price to book. Or you're
looking at the entire firm. You look at
the market price for the firm. Market
price. Market price for the firm
includes equity. It also includes debt.
But in the extend that cash is not
invested in assets. You might net it
out. That's called enterprise value. The
numerator captures what you're paying.
It can be market value of equity, market
value of the entire firm or market value
of the entire firm, net of cash,
enterprise value. In the denominator,
you have your scalar. It can be
revenues.
It can be earnings either to equity
investors of the firm. Can be cash flows
again to either equity investors or to
the firm. In fact, a very rough measure
of cash flow is to take depreciation
amotization added to your operating
income. come up with EIDA or by book
value. So the first step in this process
is to scale your price. You can compare
across companies. Second step, you got
to pick those companies you're going to
compare it to. You might pick companies
in the same business, the same
geography.
The more criteria you add to your pure
group, the smaller the pure group will
become. And maybe that's your endgame.
So there are choices you'll have to
make. If you're if you're very strict
about your choice, you'll end up with a
small sample of comparable firms. If
you're more, you know, more more
flexible about your choices, you can end
up with a larger group. So, you choose a
multiply. You pick comparable firms. And
then, let's say your company is trading
at a PE ratio of 15. Your comparable
firms are trading at a PE ratio of 20.
First side, it looks cheap, right? But
you got to ask the right questions. Is
it cheap or is there a good reason why
it trades at a lower multiple? Maybe it
is riskier. Maybe it has lower growth.
Maybe its growth is not coming in places
that add value.
Choose a multiple. Pick comparable
firms. Tell your story. That's what
every equity research report is. Equity
research reports don't value companies.
They price them. That's their mission.
And that's what pricing is about. This
is a very simple example of pricing. I
tried to price Twitter in October of
2013. I started with all the
conventional multiples. Price earnings
didn't work. Company was losing money.
Price to book didn't work. Company had
very little book value. In fact, a
negative book value of equity. You say,
"What about revenue multiples?" I tried
those. Enterprise value to sales. EIDA
multiples. You can see lot of NAS not
available.
But ultimately, the multiple that I
picked is going to surprise you. I
divide the enterprise value publicly
traded companies in the space
and divide by the number of users.
It explained difference in pricing
better than any other multiple. You
think that makes no sense.
Doesn't have to. Pricing is what the
market is using. In fact, if you took
the $100 per user, the median price per
user that you saw across companies and
applied it to the 237 million users that
Twitter had, you come up with about 24
billion. That's actually surprisingly
close to what the market price was on
that offering day. Pricing is a
pragmatic exercise. You're trying to
come up with a number for your company
based on what similar companies are
being priced at. So here are my rules
for the road. If you decide to do
pricing, first be consistent. Your
numerator and your denominator have to
be matched up. If your numerator is an
equity value, market cap, the
denominator has to be an equity value,
net income, book value of equity. If
your numerator is the entire firm,
enterprise value, denominator should two
should be to the entire firm. You could
you cannot divide enterprise value by
net income. you have to divide by
operating income or EIDA or revenues.
Second, this is about the data. Play
Moneyball. Bring in your statistical
skills to see if you can figure out why
some companies look cheap and others are
expensive. And if you're making implicit
assumptions about your company having
higher growth and less risk, try to make
them explicit.
Otherwise, you can fool yourself. And to
the extent that you can control for
differences well across companies, your
pricing will get much better. Otherwise,
all you will have is storytelling. So,
in summary, if you're asked to attach a
number to an investment, you can value
it based on cash flows, growth, and
risk, and use a discounted cash flow
model if need be, or you can price it by
standardizing the price and comparing to
other things just like this thing that
you're pricing and controlling for
differences. I hope you found the
session useful and I thank you very much
for listening.